in regards to betting earlier today i
spoke with brian benowitz from the
sportsbook at the cosmopolitan
to break down some of the unique prop
bets
hey brian thanks for joining us this is
go time for you so i'm going to hit you
with one of the hardest questions of the
year
who do you like on sunday well jc first
of all thanks for having me uh you know
i had the loser last year so this year
uh
i'm gonna redeem myself and i'm gonna
i'm not gonna make the same mistake i
did last year i'm gonna go with the
kansas city chiefs i think they're gonna
uh repeat the super bowl champions i
actually think they're going to win
fairly comfortably
covering the point spread i i think the
score will be 35-24 is the
the number i'm going with you have some
really cool prop bets going on at the
cosmopolitan let's jump into some of
these because
all right so the first one is will
either team use
all six timeouts is this a common one
that you guys have every year is this a
new bet for people to place
you know that's a great one that's
that's one that i actually have never
seen before
ever i really can't see a team using all
six timeouts that's me is a is a pretty
good one to jump on
all right so how about this one what
will be more reeves hits
or fournette's yards on his first carry
okay i i love reeves hits in this one
i'm a hockey guy
i gotta think reeves is gonna get on
sunday he's gonna be all excited for the
super bowl he's gonna get five or six
hits on those games
and fournette he can be negative i just
want your opinion on this one bet it's
not at the cosmopolitan
i don't think it's anywhere in las vegas
it's one of these offshore vetting sites
but they have uh which coach's
nostrils will be seen first because they
got to wear the mask
who is the first coach to pull his mask
down and anger on sunday
well that's a good one i'm going to go
with bruce arians on that one just
because uh
you know the the the walrus kind of it's
got that weird
uh reverse mask on and then he sometimes
he carries that's that screen on there
too so he's pretty secure
visit the cosmopolitan of las vegas dot
com to reserve your spot at the
sportsbook and
learn about their mobile betting app
rocky